[Musik]
Professor Karlo Masala von der
Universität der Bundeswehr in München
ist uns zugeschaltet guten Abend
Professor Masala
schönen guten Abend
auf diese Panzer hat die Ukraine lange
gewartet da hat sie lange darum gebeten
fast von Anfang an wie erklären Sie sich
jetzt diesen Umschwung im westlichen
Bündnis wie interpretieren sie das
ich glaube der Umschwung ist durch zwei
Entwicklungen zu erklären zum einen ist
er zu erklären dass in den vergangenen
Wochen Russland einen unglaublichen
raketenkrieg gegen die zivile
Infrastruktur dieses Landes und gegen
die Zivilisten geführt hat und keinerlei
Anstalten machte diesen auch irgendwie
einzuhalten sondern man hatte den
Eindruck russland will die Ukraine in
die Steinzeit zurückkommen und zum
zweiten ist es sicherlich auch die
endgültige Enttäuschung und die Absage
an die Idee dass ich Putin ohne
Vorbedingungen oder mit anderen
Vorbedingungen als Russland sie stellt
an den Verhandlungstisch begibt um einen
Friedensschluss mit der Ukraine zu
suchen etwas was er ja heute wiederum
abgelehnt hat und ich glaube in dieser
Kombination ist dann diese
selbstgesetzte Linie sie haben vom
Tabubruch geredet davon würde ich auch
reden aber diese selbst gesteckte Linie
der westlichen Staaten keine modernen
westlichen gepanzerten Systeme zu
liefern die ist dann gefallen und das
hat zu der Entscheidung geführt die wir
heute erlebt haben von eskalationsgefahr
ist jetzt auch keine Rede mehr
das ist ja genau der Punkt also man hat
ja immer argumentiert und sie hatten die
Einspieler ja auch von Olaf Scholz der
in Interviews immer gesagt hat der
Marder und der Leo würden eine
Eskalation bedeuten das Argument war
schon nicht mehr haltbar nachdem man den
Geparden und die Panzerhaubitze 2000 in
die Ukraine geliefert hat aber es war
noch immer sozusagen das Mantra der
Bundesregierung oder des Bundeskanzlers
jetzt scheint man endlich begriffen zu
haben dass die Lieferung bestimmter
Waffensysteme nicht notwendigerweise zu
einer Eskalation führt sondern diese
Eskalation ganz allein in der Hand von
Putin liegt egal was für Waffensystem
wenn man liefert oder nicht also könnte
es eventuell auch noch den Leo geben
oder Leo eins vielleicht dann eher
ich denke es ist ein Tabu gebrochen
worden und dieses Tabu beinhaltet dass
wir jetzt auch je nachdem wie der Krieg
in den nächsten Wochen und Monaten
weiterverlaufen wird auch über die Frage
von main battle Tanks also richtigen
Kampfpanzern das sind ja alles keine
Panzer die die richtigen Panzer die wir
jetzt liefern sondern richtige
Kampfpanzer im Sinne von Leo 2 oder
Leclerc oder Abrahams diskutieren werden
und wir werden auch sicherlich auch noch
mal die Frage diskutieren ob die in
osteuropäischen Staaten noch
existierenden alten sowjetischen
Kampfflugzeuge also die mit 29 nicht
auch etwas wäre was man in die Ukraine
liefern sollte weil das ist genau das
Gerät dass die Ukraine in dieser Phase
des Krieges dringend benötigt du keine
wollte ja auch eben diese Schützenpanzer
und später Panzer haben also eben keine
schweren aber die bringen Infanterie
nach hier und dort und haben auch
ziemlich dicke Kanone dabei warum ist
ihnen das so wichtig da geht's doch
nicht mehr nur um etwas zu halten
sondern da geht doch wahrscheinlich auch
darum nach vorne zu kommen also die
Offensive zu kommen
richtig es geht hier vor allen Dingen
sozusagen darum bei den offensiven
besser operieren zu können Soldaten
schneller und Soldatinnen auch schneller
sozusagen zu Punkten zu bringen und
besser geschützt zu Punkten zu bringen
ich meine wir haben ja Bilder aus der
Ukraine wo Soldatinnen in Pickups an die
Front gefahren werden das ist natürlich
ein untragbarer Zustand zum Schutz der
eigenen Streitkräfte dieser ist jetzt
wesentlich verbessert und durch den
französischen spätpanzer kann das
gegebenenfalls dann auch noch mal Feuer
mäßig abgesichert werden also von daher
wird jetzt Material geliefert dass die
Ukraine dringend benötigt für ihre
offensiven und gegen offensiven in den
nächsten Wochen der Chef der Ukraine ist
ukrainische Militär Geheimdienstes hatte
er angekündigt im März werde man eine
Frühlingsoffensive beginnen und sind
solche geheimdienstlichen Botschaften
auch mal mit Vorsicht zu genießen was
dahinter steckt aber da müssten sich
aber jetzt dann die Bundeswehr auch
beeilen um die Ukraine an den Mördern
auszubilden
also nach den letzten Informationen soll
die Ausbildung abgeschlossen sein im
ersten Quartal 2023 und dann sollen die
Ukraine mit dem Gerät sozusagen nach
Hause gehen und es dort einsetzen und
das ist in der Tat richtig also Zeit ist
hier der kritische Faktor das Gerät muss
relativ schnell in die Ukraine kommen
ich meine nicht nur die Ukraine wollen
offensiven machen die Russen bereiten
auch wiederum offensiven vor die aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit nach dem Frühjahr
stattfinden die Ausbildung muss schnell
erfolgen das Gerät muss schnell in die
Ukraine kommen ansonsten laufen wir
wieder in die Falle dass wir die
richtige Entscheidung getroffen haben
aber viel zu spät sozusagen das Material
in die Ukraine bringen dann hat er Putin
diese Feuerpause diese weihnachtliche
angeboten und da sagen die Ukraine also
auch Kollegen von Ihnen internationale
Professoren von internationale
internationales Recht das ist eigentlich
nur eine Finte ist das ist so eine Art
Kommunikation in den Westen und jeden
die auch mit diesen Waffenlieferungen
Probleme haben zu signalisieren
eigentlich ganz gesprächsbereit teilen
Sie diese Einschätzung
ich teile das also es ist zum einen
zynisch angesichts der Tatsache und Joe
Biden hat das ja in ihrem Bericht
erwähnt also das am 25 Dezember
Kinderkliniken bombardiert worden sind
das Silvesterraketen auf die Ukraine
herunter hagelte jetzt sozusagen diese
diese einseitige Feuerpause anzukündigen
ich glaube das ist motiviert einmal um
natürlich den Kritikern dieser
Waffenlieferung jetzt Munition zu
liefern zu sagen seht ja die Russen
bewegen sich sie rufen eine Feuerpause
aus das haben wir immer gewollt jetzt
lasst uns gucken was man daraus machen
kann zum zweiten ist es sicherlich eine
Kommunikation nach Russland hinein dass
man das orthodoxe Weihnachtsfest
respektiert und zum dritten hilft es
natürlich auch wenn diese Feuerpause
eingehalten werden sollte auch von den
Ukrainern was natürlich nicht erfolgen
wird aber dann ungestört sozusagen
weiterhin Material und Mensch an die
Front zu bringen und der vierte Punkt
ist und das haben wir ganz oft in
Kriegen und Bürger kriegen gesehen diese
Feuerpausen sind unglaublich brüchig
also da braucht es nicht viel damit man
die Gefechte wieder aufnimmt von daher
alles in allem glaube ich dass es
einfach eine zynische finde von Putin
und und seinen seinen Getreuen um hier
ein bisschen Zeit zu gewinnen
für das Gespräch